[Music]
cartoon food is just as popular as the
characters themselves have you ever
wanted to try a Scooby Snack or taste
food shaped Pokemon stay tuned to see
food items inspired by Rick and Morty if
you're new here hit that subscribe
button to never miss another video and
don't forget to give us a big thumbs up
now let's check out 10 foods inspired by
your favorite cartoons Hello Kitty Hello
Kitty is without a doubt one of the most
popular cats on the planet its history
dates back to 1974 when the illustration
of a venn nameless cat first appeared
Hello Kitty's first merchandise was a
vinyl coin purse but since then this
cool cat managed to appear just about
anywhere including food Hello Kitty
themed food is everywhere that you can
find whole Hello Kitty themed
restaurants and other pop-up shops that
show off just how popular this cat
actually is check out the Hello Kitty
inspired foods these pop-tarts look
absolutely adorable as do the donuts but
restaurants have taken it to another
level if you ever go to a Hello Kitty
themed restaurant you will find
everything from steamed buns rice and
dim sum to the decor that's dedicated to
this popular cartoon character and even
though the food is delicious it's not
easy to make a chef said that it takes
17 steps to prepare a single Hello Kitty
dim sum but luckily some items can be
prepared much faster you can even buy a
Hello Kitty toaster would you put a mark
on your breakfast toast it's by far one
of the most popular cartoon themed foods
out there and we have to admit that it
looks absolutely adorable
we'd probably eat food we don't like if
it was shaped like Hello Kitty hey guys
we are so excited to announce we are
producing our own original content head
over to the trendy for the best DIYs
fashion tips makeup acts and so much
more we are sure you're going to love it
and be sure to let us know what you
think in the comment section we love to
hear from you see you there
pokemon pokemon is also a popular choice
when it comes to themed food of course
it almost always features the one and
only Pikachu one of the most memorable
characters from the franchise did you
know that pokemons were first introduced
in 1996 and they were called capsule
monsters after the Nintendo games came
the cards movies and other merchandise
and then also came Pokemon themed food
and honestly it's the cutest thing we've
ever seen check out that Pikachu
Bulbasaur and Charmander burgers they
look absolutely delicious then we have
the ice cream that you can also easily
make it home we also found a
ridiculously adorable Snorlax bento box
do you see the Dugtrio made of sausages
it's one of the most creative mills we
have ever seen and we bet it must have
taken so long to prepare someone even
turned a regular fried egg into a
Pikachu the options are endless just
find something yellow and round and it's
guaranteed you'll be able to turn it
into a Pokemon character but our
absolute favorite are the Pokemon cakes
check them out from cupcakes to birthday
cakes these are some of the best
desserts we have ever seen what do you
think would you ever order a pokemon
theme food or is it not something you'd
like to see on the menu don't worry
there's plenty of more cartoon food to
come Winnie the Pooh in order to have a
successful cartoon themed food party
choose adorably round characters that
can be easily made with rice or burgers
Winnie the Pooh's definitely fits that
description
although the kind hearted bear is mainly
known from the books it became so
popular Walt Disney brought it to film
in 1966 did you know that Walt Disney's
daughters were huge fans of we need to
prove Walt had to admit that Winnie the
Pooh is only second to Mickey Mouse
no wonder you can find so many food
items inspired by this popular character
check these out from Tigger to Winnie
you can really make some adorable food
art with these characters we're talking
burgers rice honey
and anything else you can think of our
favorite has to be this completely
adorable Winnie the Pooh rice meal that
looks like a truth piece of ours the
tiny dumplings are also ridiculously
cute we can't imagine how much time went
into the preparation but we do know that
the food was probably devoured in a
matter of seconds check out this amazing
art made of noodles it looks so cute
it's almost too pretty to eat our
absolute favorite has to be the honey
pot cake which is so detailed it's
almost like a story on its own after all
who doesn't love cake The Simpsons of
course when it comes to popular cartoons
we absolutely have to mention the
Simpsons
the show first appeared on our screens
back in 1987 but the characters are
still bringing us laughter to this day
The Simpsons food is probably best known
for homers Donuts which he absolutely
adores and we totally understand why in
homers words is there anything that
donuts can't do if you're craving for
some donuts these pictures will
definitely make you go and buy some ASAP
it looks like they can also transform
into real-life food you can actually
make at home or get in shops check out
these pretty impressive donuts inspired
by The Simpsons we actually found a
recipe that allows you to make these at
home all you'll need is regular
ingredients to make donuts and icing
sugar and pink coloring for the
beautiful glaze on top we also recommend
adding some sprinkles to get the real
Simpsons effect but the donuts aren't
the only food you can get in real life
people have also ordered Krusty burgers
and flaming Moe drinks we have also
spotted a real-life Duff Beer and plenty
more food replicas check out this
awesome The Simpsons themed birthday
party we have to say that out of all
this theme food we still pick the
delicious pink donuts in fact we're
about to eat one right now
scooby-doo sandwich Scooby dooby doo
where are you we got some work to do now
let's take a look at a cartoon every 90s
absolutely adores scooby-doo is one of
those wonky cartoons everyone was a
little bit scared of as a kid but then
again we also adored watching this silly
dog unmask monsters did you know that
Scooby almost became a sheepdog but
luckily the production team finally
decided on a great thing the scooby-doo
food is best known for the popular
Scooby Snacks and we found a few pretty
impressive versions of this Scooby Snack
sure it might look like dog food but if
it helps us face some fears we'll take
it
Shaggy and Scooby are also seen eating
as many sandwiches and burgers as
possible do you remember the iconic
sandwich they both tried to eat here's
an example of what that would look like
in the real life raise your hands if you
can eat something as big as this Scooby
sandwich but Scooby inspired through
doesn't stop there we are completely in
love with this idea for the Scooby Doo
swab tip you never know where you could
find some lurking monsters where you a
Scooby fan as a child let us know if you
ever wondered what Scooby Snacks
tastes like because the question is
still on our minds minions if you're not
a fan of these yellow sidekicks you
should skip this part of the video now
we all thought the minions craze would
be over with the last Despicable Me
movie but it seems that these yellow
creatures are still going strong the
characters made animated movie history
and broke all box office records with
the arrival of minions the movie you
might hate them or love them but you
have to admit that the minions are
pretty funny because of their round
shape they can easily be recreated as
food check these out we've already shown
you cartoon character food art but the
minions are our favorite design yet can
you believe everything on this plate is
actually edible we also found this
creative use of bananas one of the
minions favorite foods don't they look
just like them it turns out that you can
make minions out of yellow peppers Oreos
yogurt and practically any other yellow
food you can find all you need is a few
extra ingredients and just a bit of
creativity
inspired food all with these with
totally delicious
and we wouldn't mind testing out every
single minion inspired food item what do
you think are you over minions yet or do
you still giggle when you see videos of
them singing the banana song Adventure
Time Adventure Time has a large fan base
even though the show might seem a bit
confusing to any outsider the main
characters Jake and Finn can morph into
just about anything and live and
post-apocalyptic fans of magical kingdom
we follow them through their adventures
which more than often also includes
eating food we found some amazing
adventure time inspired donut but you
can also find several food items that
look like they're straight out of the
cartoon like Marceline's mysterious red
fries that are apparently so good she
even wrote a song about them we also
found a real-life version of Jake's
perfect sandwich and judging by its
ingredients it could easily be our
perfect sandwich to the Royal tart which
is a delicacy in the Candy Kingdom also
looks like a pretty amazing meal in real
life we're particularly fond of the
tarts which are taken from thousands of
rejected tarts and turned into a perfect
dessert pretty cool right
speaking of adventure time did you know
that the plot of the show would be
completely different if it wasn't for
the business time episode in season 1
it's the episode that accidentally
introduced the post-apocalyptic world
and the team decided to just run with it
we can't even imagine what the story or
the food would look like in a different
Adventure Time world Sesame Street when
it comes to iconic cartoons we
absolutely can forget about Sesame
Street the cartoon that made most of our
childhoods the evolution of Sesame
Street is pretty impressive and you
wouldn't believe that the show's history
dates back to 1969 the characters are
still the same but their popularity
reached a new peak you've probably seen
some Sesame Street inspired food before
but let's take a look at it in more
detail the best-known character of the
show is probably the Cookie Monster and
we bet you've seen at least a few Cookie
Monster cupcakes
these look pretty impressive and they
almost seem like they're too good to be
eaten from salad and fruit bowls to some
of the most creative cakes we have ever
seen Sesame Street theme
has been extremely popular on DIY
platforms like Pinterest of course the
cupcakes are the cutest food items we
have ever seen would you even dare to
eat something as cute as these cupcakes
even the rubber duckie didn't escape the
food trend but our favored and possibly
the most impressive has to be the Cookie
Monster cake check out the insane detail
we can't imagine the time required to
make a cake like this but we're pretty
sure we'd be too afraid to eat it not
because the Cookie Monster is scary
because the cake looks too good
Sponge Bob Squarepants who lives in the
pineapple under the seat
SpongeBob SquarePants spongebob is one
of the most popular Nickelodeon shows
ever it's completely crazy but it does
make us laugh we love watching Spongebob
and his friends go in adventures but we
have to admit that we love watching
plankton finding out the secret krabby
patty formula even more of course the
krabby patty is so popular you can find
plenty of real-life versions of this
popular burger check these out they
definitely look totally delicious but
what we really want to find out is this
secret ingredient that makes them the
tastiest burgers around if you google it
you'll get a lot of results however none
have actually been confirmed by
Nickelodeon but a Reddit user had an
interesting secret formula theory what
if the secret ingredient is actually
nothing what if it's just a distraction
to make sure plankton doesn't actually
open his own restaurant if everyone
would know the secret ingredient Krabby
Patties wouldn't be unique anymore but
it's not all about the Krabby Patties
check out some of the other SpongeBob
SquarePants inspired food items we even
found the Chum Bucket and a food version
of plankton Rick and Morty eye holes one
of the most talked about shows in 2017
was definitely Rick and Morty's the
wacky show has an avid fan base of loyal
followers who can't wait to see new
adventures of this unstoppable duo once
you get into the show
you'll notice that the Rick and Morty
food is just as popular as the
characters themselves we've recently
talked about the McDonald's set to run
sauce which is frequently mentioned
by Rick and Morty fans to see just how
popular this food item is in real life
make sure you watch our video on 10
times fans to get way too far but it's
not just such a one sauce that's making
waves another popular food item is the
eyehole cereal with the eyeholes man who
beats up anyone who eats this cereal
here's what it would look like in real
life
definitely more appealing than the
actual eye holes to make these in real
life you'll need to first make brown
donuts then add a pistachio pudding as a
filling unfortunately an alien with a
megaphone is not included in any of
these real-life recipes however it would
make a pretty interesting halloween
costume of course nothing beats the
real-life statue and sauce did you know
that some people are willing to trade
their car just so they could try rick's
favorite food item and that's it for 10
foods inspired by your favorite cartoons
for more videos like this one check out
10 the loud house characters reimagined
as opposite genders see you next time
[Music]